Suppose we have the same track that we had in the past video.
My sketch is y axis, which is my x.
Let's say the track looks like this, it seems
something like that.
It's the same one we had in the last video.
May not look quite like it, let me see what I am
I did the last video.
He started like this in the last video, but he closed enough.
Suppose we are dealing with the same settings
Curve as the last video.
This curve can be called c.
Another video now, we only deal with a vector field
Vector in i direction.
Let's build with another vector field that only contains the vector in
J direction, or vertical orientation.
So let's say that, the field vector to the XY layout, say it is equal
To the capital times X and Y in J, we will worry
We ourselves are on our way to care though
Closed line integral about cq dot dt and
We saw that act.
Dr. K can be rewritten as dx times, in addition to dy times.
So if we take the product dot these two, this
An integral line would be the same thing.
This will be the same as a closed line
Integrated via C of Dr. Well, q has only a component.
So if you take [? with it?]
Is 0i, where 0 times 0x and then you will
To have an x ​​and y layout times dy.
It has no i component, so this is just going to be q,
Will switch to the same color again, p x y dy times.
This product point.
There was no i-component, that's why we lose dx.
Now let's see if there is any way we can solve this line
Integral without having to resort to a third parameter, t.
As we did in the past video.
In fact, it will be almost identical, we only deal
With the quality now instead of x marks
Even what we can do, we can say, too, what we may have
y minimum and our maximum y?
So we have the minimum y, let's say the right here.
Y lower, let us call that.
Let's say y maximum we can achieve right there.
Let us call that b.
Oh, just like in the past, I forgot to tell you
Curve direction.
But this is the same track as last time, so we're on our way
Counterclockwise.
The exact same curve, the exact same path.
So we're going in that direction.
Now in the last video, we broke into it's two functions
X, the quality of two functions as x.
Now we want to deal with quality
Let us divide into two tasks a thief.
So if we can divide this path into two tracks, that kind
And refer us to the extreme, let us call this last right here, let's
Call that right path there, let's call that y, let's call
That X of the day up here, walk on this path, x is equal to today, or
You can only write track 2, or call from c2.
We can tell him,
Equals x 2 x of y.
That is the way.
And then track first, or it should not be
The first path, depending on where you start.
You can start anywhere.
Suppose this one is in purple.
We will call this track 1, we can say, to know
Where x equals 1 x of y.
It's a bit confusing when you have x as a thief,
But it is identical to what we were really quite
I did the last video.
We're literally trading just the x and y signs.
We are now expressing x as a function of thief, instead
Thief as a function of x.
So we have these two curves.
You can only imagine flipping, and we are adjusting
The same thing that we did in the past videos, just
Now in terms of y.
But if you look at it this way, this line can be integral
Rewrite as being equal to integration, let's
Just do c2 first.
This integration of B to.
Start with B, and go to.
That is, you are returning from high y to low y.
Integrated from B to Q of the day in that gray color.
Q, instead of having x there, we know along this curve
Right here, equal to x, we want everything in terms of y.
So here, it equals x 2 x of y.
Q Up to 2 x from y, 2 x from yy comma, maybe I'm using a large number of
The colors here, but I think you get the idea.
dy.
So this is the part of the line that is embedded, just over
This curve is the left hand.
And then we'll add to that line integration, or
Really just a regular integrated now, from y equals a thief
Equals P, instead of x equals 2 x, now x
Is equal to 1 x of y, equal to this curve, this is
Another function.
So 1 x of y, 1 x of yy is a comma, dy, and we can do exactly what
We did the previous video.
Instead, we do not like the larger number at the bottom, even
Let's swap these two around.
Even if you swap these two, if you make it in, and
This is in A B, which makes the integrated negative,
When you swap the two, change the direction.
That's exactly what we did in the last video, so hopefully
It is not too fancy.
But now that we have the same limits of integration,
These integrals are two meta-tools, we can only write them down
One integrated metadata tool.
So this will not be equal to the integrated from to b.
I write this one first, so it's positive.
I am writing in this one.
Q of 1 x of yy is a comma, minus this one.
is not it?
We have the subtraction here.
Minus 2 x of y and y dy.
Let me do it in those neutral colors.
dy, which hits all these things.
I distributed out dy, I think you get the idea.
This is exactly what we did in the last video.
This can be returned, since this is equal to integration
From B to B, it is integrated within, we can evaluate
Function P x Y from the border, the top
Border, where the upper border will be of x
Equals 1 x of y, and minimum
Equals x 2 x of y.
is not it?
All the x signs we replace are Balti, and then we got some
Expression, then from that, we subtract this with x
Replace as 2 x of y.
That's exactly what we did, just as in another video,
We kind of go the opposite direction we usually do
Go in Integrations Tool Definition.
Usually we get to it, and then the next
Step, we get this.
But now we are going in reverse direction, but it is
However the difference.
And all those times are dy.
As we saw in the last video, this, let me do it
In Orange, this expression, here actually let me
Draw this dy out a bit more so no
Get all crowded.
Let me do dy here.
This expression, this full expression, is exactly the same
The integrated thing of x equals, can only be written
Here, let me write them in the same colors.
2 x from y 1 x from y 1 x from y in part q
With regard to x dx.
I want to be very clear.
That is, at least in my opinion, the first part,
A little confusing.
But if you only see an integral like this, this
From the inside of the integrated double.
And.
Exterior What we saw there, integrated
From B, D.
But if I just saw this in a dual integrated, what if you
Can you take this anti-adaptive,
It is anti-adaptive in relation to DS,
Antivirative micro-q with respect to x
It is about, and it will not be just q and y.
Because it is an integrated meta-tool, you can evaluate it
1 x of y, then subtract from it, this function
Evaluate 2 x of y, which is exactly what we did.
I wish you appreciate it.
Then we got our score, which is very similar
That last result.
What does this represent a double integral?
It represents, too, anything, if you have any integrated double
To go out of the day if you imagine, these are some function,
Let me draw it in three dimensions.
This is really almost a review of what we did
In the last video.
If this is the y axis, which of us is the x-axis, this is the focus of our work "p".
These are some X and Y function, even some surface you
Can be visualized on the XY plane.
It is some surface.
So we can call this partial q in relation to.
Etc. This is a dual integrated, that's basically
Select a region, and you can sort of display the times of this DX
dy as a small difference type in the area.
The area under question, border points, of y
Go from, go y from the bottom, go from 2 x from y,
Our opinion is a curve that looks something like that.
This is the lowest y, here, if we put in two
Dimensions, this was the lowest y-curve.
The y-curve of the upper is 1 x of y, where y-looks the upper curve
something like that.
The upper y-curve is rich in something like this.
So x differs from the bottom-y-curve to the top
Y-Curve, right?
That's what we're doing here.
And then y differs from to b.
So this is basically saying, let's take the multiplier
This area is integrated here for this function.
So it's basically the volume, if this is the maximum,
This border is essentially a wall.
The size of that room is.
I do not know what it will look like when
They come here.
But you can imagine something in kind like that.
The size will be that.
That's what we do.
This is a match result we got in the last video.
This is a very neat thing.
So suddenly, this carrier, so - and o x, and I
I did not draw it as I did the last time, so r
Just [? Things?]
J-direction, so just him, if I had to draw her
Vector field, carriers just go up or down.
They have no horizontal component to it.
But we saw, when you start using a vector field like this, you can
Take the integrated line around this closed loop, and will
Write it here, you can take this integral line around this
Close the loop Dr Q Dot, which is worth about integrated around
Closed loop of P and O dy.
Only we calculate that this is twice the equivalent
Integrated across the region.
This is the region.
is not it?
That's exactly what we're doing here.
If I just give you the area, you'll know it, if you're
I say, also, being x of, this happens from this
The function to this function, the P goes from to B, and you
You may want to check the dual video parcel, if
That confuses you.
Where we multiply the parcel on the area
Micro-of q with respect to x, d-well, can write dx
So right di, or you can da little, right?
Teams hand, to the right, which we can imagine
Kda, the same thing dx dy.
And if we combine that with the last video, this kind
Sleek make it all part together, result
This was the last video.
It is a function that knows exactly where
x, we had, that's right here.
We had that result.
In fact, let me copy and paste both of them into a nice clean
Part of my blackboard board, and then we can do
The result is exciting.
Let me copy and paste this.
That's what we got in the last video.
And this video, we got this result.
I just copy and paste this part right there.
You might already predict where it is going.
And then let me paste it here.
This is the output of this video.
Now let's think of an arbitrary vector field but it is
He knows, I'll do pink, let's say and be a vector
Define the field over the plane X and Y, equal and P
To add to VHS.
You can almost imagine and are adding us destined
The fields, p and q, that we did in the last two videos.
P this video, we did P in the video before it.
But this really is any arbitrary vector field.
Let's say we want to field carrier, or sorry,
An integrated line for this vector pathology, along some pathway.
It could be the same as the one we did, which it was
Very random password.
It's really no arbitrary course.
So let me draw some arbitrary path over here.
Let's say, this is my arbitrary way, my arbitrary curve.
Let's say it goes in this direction counterclockwise,
Just like that.
I am interested in including the integral line, closed line
Integrated, about this path from Dr. Dutt.
We have seen this several times.
Dr. Equal to dx I additionally times dy.
Where such an integral line can be returned, and this is equal
To the integrated line around the c path.
And Dr. Dot, which is about to dx times this term, so that
DS and DX times in addition to this term, XY and YDY times.
And that's all, basically this is the same
The thing as an integrated line of xy dx, in addition to the line
The integral of the Q and Y dy.
Now what are these things?
That's what we figured in the first video, that's what
We have now figured it out in this video.
This thing here is the same thing
As there is.
So this will not be equal to an integrated doubling over this
The area is right here, from the micro-minus of the p-y.
Instead of DX Dy, we can say just over
The difference in the region.
And then plus this one, this result.
F.
This is something here exactly what we've just proven,
Exactly what we just showed in this video.
This is in addition, I'll leave it there, maybe I'll do it
Yellow, plus dual integration on the same area
Of partial q in relation to.
Da, where this is just dy dx, or dx dy, you can
System switch,
Area teams.
Now, we can add these two integrals.
What do we get?
So this is worth, and this is kind of our business
Great, great conclusion.
Purple may be called here.
Integrated double around the area, I write this one
First because it is positive, negative, from
Micro-of-q with respect to x, minus micro-p with
Respect y, d, and difference in the area.
This is our big meals.
Let me write here.
Equals the integrated line of the closed loop of Dr
Dual integrated for this expression.
And nothing, just remember.
We do the function that was associated with it
x-component or element i, we do
Partial regarding y.
And the function to which he was associated
Y-component, we do partial regards.
And this is the first one, we deny it.
This is a good way to remember them.
But this is the right result here, and this, perhaps I should
Writing in green, this is a theorem in green.
And it is a clean way connected to an integrated line in a vector field
Contains these partial derivatives, assuming they are
These derivatives are partial, to the region, for a double data type
Integrated area.
Now, this is a little side note, we've seen the
Clip several before, we learned that if and
Conservative, which means that the gradient of some functions,
It is independent of the track, that the integration is closed around
Any path is equal to 0.
That is still true.
So that tells us that if the conservative, this is the right thing
Here should be equal to 0.
This is the only way you always have to force that
This whole integral will be equal, and will be equal
0 across any area, ie, ie.
I'm sure you think about situations where it is
Cancel each other, but the truth on any area.
This is the only way that this will be true.
That these two things will be equal to 0.
So then you can say, partial q with respect to x, minus
Partially in relation to a product, it must be equal to 0, or
These two things have been equal to each other.
or.
This kind of result is natural to Greene's theory.
The type of low hanging fruit can be calculated.
Partial q in relation to x is equal to micro
From p to y.
And when you study the exact equations in the difference
Equations, you'll see this a lot.
In fact, well, I will not go into much, but conservatives
Fields, you actually, differential shape what
Look at the line integrals, if conservative, it
Be accurate equation.
But will not go that much.
But it is hoped that you may see similarities if you've already run
In precise equations in differential equations.
But this is a big meal, let's probably do some
Examples of using these meals in the next video.